COME TO ORDER. HE. WE'RE OKAY
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVE IN NINETEEN
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND STAFF WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND HERE
IT'S A SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE ORDERS THE
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO OUR NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE SAFE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE'RE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARING
TODAY HERE IN THE CAPITAL- I ASK
ALL MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO
BE PRESENT IN THE SENATE
CHAMBERS AND LOOKS LIKE WE'RE
DOING WELL SO FAR SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH OUR QUORUM TO ALLOW
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC- IN THIS-
CHAMBERS IN OUR HEARING ROOM
TODAY BUT TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING ALLOWS FOR IT
AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY TELEPHONICALLY- FOR ANYONE
WISHING TO PROVIDE TELEPHONIC
PUBLIC COMMENT- THE- TOLL FREE
NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED
ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE- BUT I
WILL STATE IT NOW. THE NUMBER IS. 877-336-4437 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. EIGHT TWO SIX EIGHT
FOUR TWO EIGHT. THE MORE
INFORMATION INSTRUCTIONS ON OUR
WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU'LL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT OR PROPOSITION
PRICES ONLY ONE TIME AND THEN
PLEASE WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOUR LINE
NUMBER. ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER AT THAT TIME
YOU'LL BE ON MUTED AND CAN
SPEAK. UP PLEASE NOTE- THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY
AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I
NEED TO MUTE THE DEVICE THAT
YOU'RE WATCHING THE HEARING ON
WHILE YOU'RE GIVING YOUR
TELEPHONIC TESTIMONY- SO- ONE
SECOND. WE HAVE ONE BILL ON
TODAY'S AGENDA- AND BEFORE WE
START- WE WILL- ESTABLISH A
QUORUM SO MADAM CONSULTANT IF
YOU COULD PLEASE. SELFISH FORM.
WINNER PRESENT WINNER HERE AIDS
HERE BAITS HERE CORTEZ. CORTEZ
HE HERE COVER YOUR OWN. MCGUIRE
HERE MCGUIRE HERE ADOBO BUT YOUR
BOOK HERE SKINNER. YEAH SKINNER
HERE ON BURKE WHAT CASKEY YEAH
WE CAN SEE HERE WITH CORN. ARM
HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED- SO WE WILL
NOW HEAR OUR FIRST AND ONLY
BILL- BY SENATOR HERTZBERG
INSTRUMENTS ALREADY LEADER
WELCOMING YOU MAY PRESENT SENATE
BILL FIVE THIRTEEN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS-
MOST DIRECTLY THIS BILL REQUIRES
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT TO
ESTABLISH A GRANT PROGRAM TO
PROVIDE FUNDING. TO HOMELESS
SHELTERS TO PROVIDE SHELTER FOOD
AND BASIC VETERINARY SERVICES
FOR PETS OWNED BY INDIVIDUALS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. WHY
ARE WE DOING THIS AND WHAT HAS
HAPPENED OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS. WHAT WE'VE LEARNED IS AS
WE HAVE ENGAGED IN A SERIES OF
ENDEAVORS TO TRY TO. DO WITH
THIS CHALLENGING ISSUES WITH
PEOPLE WHO ARE WITHOUT HOMES. IS
IT MANY OF THEM HAVE PETS. THAT
ARE CRITICAL TO THEIR LIVES THEY
PROVIDE COMFORT AND EVERYTHING
VALUABLE TO THEM. AND I'VE
PERSONALLY GONE TO SOME OF THE
SHELTERS WHERE PEOPLE SAY THEY
WON'T GO INTO THEM BECAUSE THEY
WON'T TAKE THEIR PETS. THE DATA
IS A LITTLE DIFFERENT AMONG
DIFFERENT INSTITUTIONS BUT THE
BOTTOM LINE IS A SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER PROBABLY TEN TO FIFTEEN
PERCENT. OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
LIVING ON THE STREETS HAVE PETS.
SO AS WE SPEND MONEY AND SO MANY
DIFFERENT WAYS TO GET PEOPLE TO
COME INTO SHELTERS THIS IS ONE
OF THE MOST HUMANE. AND SIMPLEST
AND LEAST EXPENSIVE MATE
MEASURES. I'VE HAD THIS BILL
THIS IS THE THIRD TIME I'VE BEEN
UP HERE WITH THIS BUILD AND-
WHAT HAPPENED WAS THE FIRST TIME
WE DIDN'T DO THAT JUST I WISH
THE PROGRAM BUT WE PUT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS AND IT WAS MORE
THAN DOUBLE THE SERBS
OVERSUBSCRIBED FOR THE GRANT
PROGRAM. AND I'VE SEEN AROUND
THE STATE A NUMBER OF THESE
VARIOUS ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
OVER THE MOON. AND PEOPLE WHOSE
LIVES HAVE BEEN TURNED UPSIDE
DOWN BECAUSE OF IT. THE NEXT
YEAR CAME BACK AND WENT TO TEN
MILLION DOLLARS WHICH WAS
RECENTLY APPROVED IN THE BUDGET
WE APPROVED LAST YEAR. ON THE
FIFTEENTH AND THE FIFTEENTH OF
JUNE COMING UP FOR NEXT YEAR- SO
DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR IT'S
THOUGHTFUL IT'S INTELLIGENT YOU
MAIN WORKS ON AND IT'S BEEN
SUBSTANTIALLY OVERSUBSCRIBED
WHAT I'M ASKING THIS COMMITTEE
TODAY IS TO MAKE THIS PERMANENT
OBVIOUSLY SUBJECT TO
APPROPRIATIONS. BUT INSTEAD OF
THAT WE BASICALLY DONE TWO
PILOTS THAT I'VE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL. WITH EVERYBODY ELSE
SUPPORT HERE TO GET INTO THE
BUDGET. BUT BUDGET SHARE. IS BUT
TO MAKE THIS PROGRAM PERMIT OF
COURSE EACH YEAR SUBJECT TO
APPROPRIATION BUT TO ACTUALLY
SAY WE'VE GOT SOME THAT WORKS.
THAT'S COST EFFECTIVE THE TWO
MAIN THAT'S INTELLIGENT. AND
GETS PEOPLE OFF THE STREET AND
TAKES CARE OF THEIR PETS- ASK
YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS MISSION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR AND
YOU HAVE A LEAD WITNESSES AND
OTHER SUPPORTERS BUT- OTHER THAN
THE ONE THAT SAYS SIMILAR
LICENSES GRANTED JOHN OF COURSE
NEVER READ ANYTHING. THAT'S
GIVEN TO ME LET'S SEE IF IT SAYS
YES I HAVE WITNESSES WE HAVE THE
GREAT CAN CRAFT. PRESIDENT OF
HOPE OF THE VALLEY RESCUE
MISSION IN SANTA SAN FERNANDO IN
THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY WHOSE
FACILITIES I HAVE VISITED. AND
WHERE WE DELIVER THE TEN MILLION
DOLLAR CHECK LAST TIME AND SUSAN
RIGGS THE AMERICAN SOCIETY FOR
THE PREVENTION OF CRUELTY. TO
ANIMALS OKAY THANK YOU SO- EACH
OF THOSE WITNESSES WILL RECEIVE
TWO MINUTES- AND I ALSO YOU ARE
KEY TO THE TIME LIMIT- AND SO WE
WILL PROCEED TO THE WITNESSES.
MR MISTER OR MADAM. THANK YOU
WHICH LINE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
BEGIN WITH- SENATOR WHO WAS THE
CRAFT CAN CRAFT PRESENT HOPE OF
THE VALLEY THANK YOU. MR CRAFTER
LINE IS OPEN. GREAT WELL THANK
YOU IT'S ALWAYS A PRIVILEGE TO
BE ABLE TO BE A PART OF
SOMETHING THAT IS CHANGING THE
TRAJECTORY OF THE HOMELESS
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS THAT WE ALL
SEE HASN'T PULLED AROUND THE
THANK YOU SENATOR HERTZBERG AND
OTHER LEGISLATORS AND- LEADERS.
WHO REALLY NEED TAKING IT
SERIOUSLY- IN A COUPLE WEEKS AGO
I HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF.
INTENTIONALLY LIVING ONE HUNDRED
HOURS ON SHELTER ON THE STREETS
OF LOS ANGELES IT WAS A
DELIBERATE ATTEMPT TO WALK A FEW
MILES IN THE FOOTSTEPS OF THOSE
TO HAPPEN THEY DID EVERY DAY. IN
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE CAN
ONLY REVEAL TO ME AND THAT IS
STAYING SOBER AND STAYING SANE
WHILE LIVING ON THE STREET. IS
NEAR IMPOSSIBLE. JUST THE LONG.
THE FEAR. OF BEING. NOT HAVING
MORE NOT HAVING A WORLD. AND
I'LL BE HONEST WITH YOU I WANTED
MY DOG WITH ME I LOVE MY DOG AND
I THOUGHT MAN I WOULD FEEL SO
MUCH SAFER GET MY BOX OF DOG WAS
SLEEPING NEXT TO ME. AND I HAD
THE PRIVILEGE OF OVERHEATING
SIXTEEN HOMELESS SHELTERS IN THE
GREATER SAN FERNANDO VALLEY.
AREA AND I HAVE SEEN FIRST HAND
THAT BY NOT ALLOWING HAD BECOME
INTO THE SHELTERS WE ARE PUTTING
UP BARRIERS BETTER HEALTH THAT
ARE PREVENTING PEOPLE FROM
ENDING THEIR HOMELESSNESS. AND
SO I CANNOT. STRONGLY ENDORSED.
THE BILL MORE THAN SIMPLY SAYING
WE NEED THIS IT IS PART OF THE
CRITICAL COMPONENT IN CRITICAL
PATHWAY HELPING PEOPLE IMPACTED
THE STREET AND EXITING
HOMELESSNESS FOR GOOD BY MAKING
SURE WE'RE CARING FOR BOTH ENDS
HERTZBERG SAYS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- WE WILL NOW PROCEED TO THE
SECOND WITNESS. A LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON HERE WE ARE AND
THE PRESIDENT AND HELPING MANY
MANY MISCUES AND READ YOUR
DIRECTOR OF HEALTH AND QUALITY
FOR THE AREA. J. FOUNDED IN
EIGHTEEN SIXTY SIX THE ASPCA.
HUMANE SOCIETY. NORTH AMERICA
TODAY IT'S ONE OF THE WORLD'S
LARGEST. THE ANTI PEOPLE AARON
HE CAN'T BELIEVE THAT PEOPLE
BELONG TOGETHER THE FINANCIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES ARE NOT A RELIABLE
INDICATOR FOR THE CAPACITY TO
LOVE I CAN HEAR YOU CAN CARE FOR
COMPANION ANIMAL. STRONG BONDS
BETWEEN PEOPLE AND PETS MAKE FOR
STRONGER COMMUNITIES. AT THE
TIME OF EXTRAORDINARY STRESS AND
UNCERTAINTY THE NOTIONAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH BENEFITS THAT
PROVIDE. IN THE TRAUMA SECTION
DISPLAYS OR HOME OKAY ARE
CRITICAL. UNFORTUNATELY MOST OF
THE HOUSING CREATED IN PRIOR
DECADES TO PROVIDE A SAFETY NET
FOR THOSE EXPERIENCING EMERGENCY
HEALTH NEEDS WERE NOT DESIGNED
TO ACCOMMODATE HAT AND YET THE
BODY OF RESEARCH. HAS GROWN
EXPONENTIALLY IN RECENT YEARS TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT BY ALLOWING HAT
WE REMOVED A SIGNIFICANT. DATE
CABLE HOUSING. SPECIALLY AMONG
THE CHRONICALLY HOMELESS. THIS
RESEARCH SHOWS. THAT ANIMAL
COMPANIONSHIP AND FORTIFYING IT
CONTRIBUTE TO THE EMOTIONAL WELL
BEING OF THE PEOPLE AT. THAT
HOWEVER DUE TO THE LIMITED
AVAILABILITY OF PET FRIENDLY
SHELTER DEPARTMENT HEADS HAD
OWNERSHIP OFTEN AT THE BEGINNING
AND BARRIER TO ENTRY FOR HIMSELF
TO KEEP ALL. SENTENCE REPORT
PROGRAM PROVIDES AN ELEGANT AND
LOW COST SOLUTION FOR REMOVING
THAT BARRIER IN FACT RARE TO
HAVE SUCH A- LOW HANGING FRUIT
WHEN IT COMES TO CORRECT THING.
IF YOU LOOK FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THE GRANT AMOUNT ALIVE
DURING THE FIRST ROUND OF THE
NOTICE OF FUNDING AVAILABILITY
PROVIDED BY ECD RANGE FROM HIGH.
END TO THE MAXIMUM OF TWO
HUNDRED POUNDS AND PROGRAM HE
AND VERY SMALL INVESTMENT TO
ENSURE THAT WE CAN DO I KNOW HOW
NEIGHBORS. FROM THE STREET THEY
ARE MORE STABLE ENVIRONMENT.
ENERGY DURING THE FIRST ROUND
GRANT HE REPEATED BACK IN THE
BACK RICK SANTORUM AND ALLOWING
THE FACILITY DID NOT PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY REPLICATING. ALSO
DEFIED THE COURT FOR BOTH OWNER
AGAIN HAD FOR THE LONG TERM
EXACTLY PERMANENT HELPING THANK. YOU VERY VERY MUCH. AND ABOUT
THAT BY THIRTEEN- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I WILL NOW MOVE TO GENERAL-
PUBLIC- IS ANYONE IN THE
GALLERY- WE TO TESTIFYING SO OF
A SPEED FIVE. I DON'T SEE ANYONE
WE DO KNOW HAVE AN O. OVER
TODAY- SO WE WILL NOW GO TO THE
PHONES OF THE MODERATOR- PLEASE
OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR PEOPLE
WISHING TO TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIVE THIRTEEN AND AS A
REMINDER WE'VE ALREADY HAD OUR
LEAD TESTIMONY SO PLEASE LIMIT
YOUR TESTIMONY TO YOUR NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION IF ANY AND THE FACT
OF YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. IF
YOU'D LIKE TO JOIN THE QUEUE TO
SHARE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL. USING YOUR PHONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
AGAIN USING YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD I MEAN PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO TO SHARE SUPPORT. WE DO
HAVE A FEW LINES IN Q. MISTER
CHAIR ONE MOMENT PLEASE. OUR
FIRST LINE OF SUPPORT WILL BE
LINE TWELVE ONE TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ALL THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATORS MATT ROBINSON
THE HAPPENED. THE UNITED STATES
. THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE LINE
TEN ONE ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON ELIZABETH ALL
RIGHT NATIONAL MANAGER OF
HOUSING INITIATIVE FOR BEST
FRIENDS ANIMAL SOCIETY HERE IN
FULL SUPPORT F. B. FIVE THIRTEEN
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH UNDER HER.
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE. LINE. THIRTEEN
ONE THREE. THANK YOU SENATOR MY
NAME IS WENDY FOR HIGHLY CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE ANIMAL LEGAL
DEFENSE FUND WE WOULD LIKE TO GO
ON THE RECORD IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE THIRTEEN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. NINE FOURTEEN ONE FOUR.
AFTERNOON MISTER KAREN MEMBERS
MEDICAL DELIGHT WITH POLITICAL
SOLUTIONS ON BEHALF OF MARS INC
AND MARS PETCARE AND SPORT THANK
YOU. AND OUR FINAL LINING CUES
LINE FIFTEEN ONE FIVE. CLOTURE
NUMBERS CAROLINE SPRINGS DOWNING
ON BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE THIRTEEN THANK YOU. YOU
KNOW FOR THE LINE THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- WILL NOW GO TO A POSITION
IF ANY TO US B. FIVE THIRTEEN-
OTHERS NO REGISTERED OPPOSITION
AND NO NEED WITNESSES
IDENTIFIED. IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE GALLERY- WISHING TO TESTIFY
AGAINST SP FIVE THIRTEEN I SEE
NO ONE AGAIN WE DO NOT HAVE AN
OVERFLOW ROOM TODAY SO WE WILL
GO. TO THE PHONE LINES- WELL THE
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY
OPPOSITION- TO SP FIVE THIRTEEN
PLEASE. LET ME KNOW HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE QUEUED UP. AGAIN
STATED POSITION OF OPPOSITION ON
THIS BILL PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO USING YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. AGAIN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO THE STATE
OPPOSITION. I'M HAVING ALLOWED A
MOMENT FOR. RESIDENTS TO PLACE
THEMSELVES IN JUNE THAT WE HAVE
NO ONE IN THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME
OKAY GREAT OKAY GREAT THANK YOU-
WHEN I BRING THE ITEM BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE- I WANT TO
PERSONALLY THANK THE AUTHOR FOR-
CONTINUING TO PURSUE THIS-
IMPORTANT ISSUE- WE KNOW THAT SO
MANY PEOPLE WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS- DO YOU HAVE-
ANIMALS USUALLY. USUALLY A DOG
BUT NOT ALWAYS- AND FOR MANY
REASONS THE FORMER
COMPANIONSHIP- IT'S A FORMER
SECURITY- IT'S A FOR A FAMILY.
OF FOUR PEOPLE WHO REALLY ARE.
SO EASILY DETACHED FROM SOCIETY
IN SO MANY WAYS- AND YOU KNOW
THE OLD WAY OF LOOKING AT IT
WERE YOU CAN'T BRING. A PET WITH
YOU INTO A HOMELESS SHELTER WAS
JUST. EVEN THOUGH I UNDERSTAND
WHY OPERATIONALLY THEY- HUH THE
RULES EXISTED IT SAYS VERY.
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE TO MAKING IT
EASY FOR PEOPLE TO COME IN OFF
THE STREETS. TO ACCESS SERVICES
TO TRANSITION TOWARDS HOUSING-
AND SO THESE NEW MODELS WERE
LIKE A NAVIGATION CENTER WHERE
PEOPLE CAN COME IN WITH THEIR
BELONGINGS. WITH HER PARTNER AND
WITH THEIR ANIMALS- IS
INCREDIBLY- EMPORIUM AND HELPS
PEOPLE- GET HEALTHY AND HEAL AND
TRANSITION TO. A BETTER LIFE SO
I REALLY WANT TO FIND. OUT THE
OFFERINGS FOR INCLUDING-
RELAYING THE VETERINARY SERVICES
BECAUSE THAT'S ANOTHER- ISSUE
MAKING SURE THESE- PETS. ARE
HEALTHY- SO I'M- RECOMMENDING AN
AIBO ON THOSE- BILL IS THERE
ANY- COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. OKAY
SITTING. DO WE HAVE A MONET AT
MAGNOLIA CENTER MY CALCIUM LEVEL
JUST MOVE THE BILLS. IT'S CENTER
MIKE MICHALSKI HAS MOVED THE
BARREL CLOSING AND WE WILL FOR
THE OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CLOSE YEAH I JUST WANTED TO SAY
TO US SHARE WITH THE COMMITTEE
THAT. IT WAS TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN CENTER THAT YOU WERE
WORKING ON THE SAME IDEA
TOGETHER. AND THAT YOU WERE PART
OF THIS AT THE VERY OUTSET AND
THEY'VE BEEN- IN YOUR HOUSING
BILL I THINK IT WAS EIGHTEEN OR
NINETEEN I CAN'T HEAR WHAT
YOU'RE IT WAS BUT I REMEMBER
HAVING LONG CONVERSATIONS WITH
YOU AND- PARTNERING WITH YOU ON
THIS I JUST WANTED TO. TELL YOU
HOW MUCH I APPRECIATE THAT NO
ONE ECHO THE WORDS OF SUSAN
RIGGS. WHETHER SHE CAPTURED BEST
THIS IS AN ELEGANT. LOW COST
SOLUTION. FOR ON HOUSE NEIGHBORS
AND THEIR PETS ASTRONOMICAL. WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR LIKE
KELSEY- AND MOUNTAIN SONG CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
SENATE BILL FIVE ONE THREE BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR WIENER HI. WINNER FIVE
BATES. BATES I COVER EURO.
CORTESE COURTESY I REQUIRE I
REQUIRE I WHICH- BOOK. PHOTOBOOK
BY SKINNER. SKINNER HI AMBER
WHAT CASKEY HI. SEVEN ZERO.
SEVEN ZERO EIGHT FIVE V. ITEM
PASSES SEVEN ZERO. I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR HERTZBERG-
THIS IS THE ONLY ITEM ON OUR
AGENDA AND SO WITH THAT. OUR
BUSINESS IS CONCLUDED AND WE ARE
ADJOURNED.